turning overseas to afghanistan the
taliban are putting down scattered
protests while their leaders insist they
will not harbor terrorists in that
country at the kabul airport meanwhile
some people were seen handing their
children to u.s troops guarding the
perimeter our roxanna saberi is in qatar
tracking the evacuation and the
desperate efforts to get out
good morning a senior u.s border
official tells cbs news his agency is
busy screening afghans who arrive here
in doha before they travel to military
bases in the u.s but still many can't
even make it this far
the main route out of afghanistan
remains a scene of despair families so
worried for the future they're handing
their children to u.s troops while
thousands push
wait and long for a flight to freedom
so finally
i'm getting to the airport
mee mahmudi a former translator for the
u.s military filmed his attempts earlier
this week i'm still in tears
unfortunately it's almost like keeping
fire on people
twice he failed so it's six o'clock came
in morning so
i'm just wake up so today i've planned
to go airport in june mahmoud told
charlie dagda he risked his own life to
save the lives of american soldiers they
hugged me and they kissed me
now the taliban are back in power he
says he's in more danger than ever
they will kill me and they will behave
me they will behead you of course
are you afraid of being left behind so i
have already left behind
since saturday u.s forces have evacuated
around 9 000 people from kabul airport
mostly u.s citizens and afghans who once
worked for the u.s
we joined hundreds of them on a u.s
military transport plane on wednesday
night
but on the ground another journey begins
this video on a u.s air base shows
conditions as people wait to be
processed one man tells us around 2 000
afghans and u.s citizens are here
crowded and hot
many people wait hours for food he says
but they're still grateful for all the
u.s is giving them
and we just heard back from mahmoud the
former translator he didn't make it onto
a flight today he said this time he was
turned back not by the taliban but by
u.s troops anthony roxanna thank you